hi I'm Jim al-khalili and here's my
question for you professor gross do you
think that we are any closer to really
reconciling the forces of nature deep
what is what is your view on string
theory and whether one day we will have
a theory of everything hi Jen so your
question is will we ever have a theory
of everything
I don't know I'm agnostic on the subject
usually the way that question is asks
presumes that we know what everything is
what are all the questions we would like
to answer and the history of science
tends to teach us that once we think
once we have achieved the answer to all
the questions we can ask in a given area
such as the fundamental laws of physics
for example new questions arise that we
didn't know how to ask before we didn't
know enough to ask those questions and
although we have achieved the theory of
everything we knew how to ask about way
back then now we have new questions
which whose answers we don't know so I
think at the present the questions we
ask are are quite profound and deep and
they seem to include all possible
questions we could ask about elementary
particles and forces and fundamental
laws of physics but most likely if a if
a an attempt such as that of string
theory were ever to succeed and it might
very well in answering all the questions
we can post today most likely we will
not have achieved a theory of everything
we will have simply achieved a theory of
all the questions we know how to ask and
at that time we will realize that there
are new questions at the moment we don't
know enough to add
that will still be open conceivably at
some point we'll start running out of no
questions to ask and in that case there
might very well be a final theory of
everything but at the moment there's not
much evidence that were close to that
point